sur l'une des plages les plus
touristiques de la martinique
les plus jeunes sont nombreux à barboter
trop occupé à fabriquer leurs souvenirs
d'enfance insouciant trop parfois
alors les parents veillent il faut
toujours rester à côté d'elle parce que
la foule a failli se noyer mal
débrouillé mais la fessée noyées quand
même je vais toujours à côté d'elle il
faut rester là il la regarde les jeux
tout près et si c'est pas profond donc
ces pratiques
pourtant la vigilance des parents ne
suffit pas le nombre de noyades ne cesse
d'augmenter
il a triplé en quelques années pour
atteindre 10 décès en 2017 et les
enfants sont les plus touchés
malgré l'utilisation de brassards ou de
gillet la chance doit être effective il
faut que l'enfant le parent l'adulte
soit à côté de l'enfant et non sur la
plage entre le lit ou de dettes au
téléphone il faut que le parlant froide
ballot avec l'enfant c'est ça qui
s'appelle l'assurance des noyades qui
surviennent en quelques secondes
gervais civette maître nageur depuis 20
ans a déjà assisté à des drames
d'ailleurs les adultes aussi sont
concernés par les noyades souvent à
cause d'un malaise dû à la fatigue ou
l'absorption d'alcool fait de se baigner
ne pas souligner est toujours dit si
d'être un dieu que le xiu veulent quoi
de pour éviter ce genre d'un
d'accidents le plus bas à voir des
familles ennuis quoi méfiance également
aux abords des piscines dans un cadre
familier la tension est souvent relâchés
pour le syndicat des maîtres nageurs il
faut que tous les enfants sachent
parfaitement nager c'est vrai que c'est
long c'est vrai que bon ben ça prend du
temps pour avoir mon apprentissage il
faut faut compter plusieurs années il
faut que vraiment que les jeunes
apprennent à nager avec des maîtres
nageurs sauveteurs diplômés d'état
savoir nager un apprentissage
indispensable une arme pour les enfants
surtout lorsqu'ils vivent entourés d'eau